[Music]
it is september 13th
1833
in the northeastern indian port city of
kolkata
it is 90 degrees outside and the air is
humid
you're in a crowd anxiously waiting
unsure if you're about to see a
historical feat of human ingenuity
or an elaborate prank
then slowly and steadily off the horizon
a brick named tuscany approaches
in it
a hundred tons of eyes
cut in blocks and stack neatly against
one another having just finished a
four-month voyage
all the way from boston
what you just witnessed was a journey
along one of the first international
temperature controlled supply chain
also known as
the cold chain
the man behind this cold chain was
frederick tudor deservedly nicknamed the
ice king
tudor started this icy empire by
harvesting natural ice in the dead of
new england winter
then delivering it first across the
united states and eventually to great
britain and india
while this journey was long and its
historical significance monumental
tudor's cold chain from a logistical
perspective was extraordinarily simple
for a long time the only commodity he
transported was ice and ice kept itself
cool as long as there was sufficient
insulation
so tudor invested heavily in these ice
houses along the ports and his business
took off
now in the two centuries that followed
the cold chain had come a long way
today the cold chain is more complex and
more global than ever before
just to give you a sense of its scale
and complexity
nowadays for a piece of imported fruit
to get to you and me it will roughly go
through 20 steps
here's a chart just to show you what
that's like
in the last three years working as a
food investor
i have seen this process in play day in
and day out in lettuce fields in soup
plants and in refrigerated trucks
delivering imported cheese to pizzerias
all across new york city
i marveled at this well-oiled machine
that connects growers manufacturers
distributors retailers and consumers
the cold chain enables us to introduce
diversity and abundance into our diet
it removes seasonality and distances
from food
it gives us choices so that food is not
just about survival but part of our
identity
that is
until this all stopped working
many of these images may look familiar
to you
bagel shops without cream cheese
starbucks without frappuccino kfc
without chicken tenders
for me a broken cold chain meant
spending hours on the phone with our
logistics providers telling them how
unacceptable it was
for them to leave frozen ready meals in
a hot truck for 24 hours too
long our coaching is susceptible to
disruptions and we've had an awful lot
of disruptions in the last two years
not only that the coaching is also
fossil fueled and incredibly energy
intensive according to the un
the food cold chain accounts for about
1.2 gigatons of co2 emissions that is
about 1 of total global annual emissions
so in between worrying about the revenue
loss from customers receiving spoiled
food and the cost associated with that
extra pack of dry eyes i now need to
budget for in the delivery
i couldn't help but wonder
how can we make this better
one solution came to mind
and it's almost too obvious and too
logical
why not simplify the supply chain do
what the industry calls near shoring
take out a few nodes here and there
shorten the distance traveled
source locally eat farm to fork it's
simple sustainable and more resilient
right
not so fast
to illustrate just how complicated the
cold chain is and how hard it is to
disentangle even a tiny portion of it
let me take you on a journey of one
commodity
walk into any western european
supermarket you will see these beautiful
uniform fresh french green beans these
beans were in the fields just 48 hours
ago in the rural villages outside bobo
du lasso in burkina faso
among many other former european
colonies in africa
these beans were hand-picked by local
manual labor when it's hot and sunny
outside and then immediately chill to
about 40 degrees fahrenheit to ensure
high export quality
they're then loaded onto refrigerated
trucks to be packed at a temperature
controlled facility
then
lastly loaded onto a jet flying directly
to paris
now what is missing from this picture of
seamless modern miracle is the fact that
many of these villages don't have paved
roads or electricity
these farmers rely
on charcoal to chill the beans instead
of refrigerators before sending the
beans to an air-conditioned facility to
be processed
many of these farmers also have come to
rely on this high value export crop as
their sole source of income
and they import shelf-stable food
for their own consumption
now if we decide that we want to
insource the beans these farmers would
lose their livelihood and the local
economy would collapse but perhaps most
ironically those who grow the beans
cannot even afford to eat them the lack
of cold storage meant that most of these
beans would rot
before the locals could get a chance to
consume them
you see
eating locally requires refrigeration
and refrigeration
is simply
too expensive
in fact scientists estimate that
as much as 40 percent of the fresh food
produced in africa is lost due to
inadequate cold chains annually
globally
the carbon footprint of food loss and
food waste is four times the carbon
footprint of the cold chain itself
so
counterintuitively for us to solve for a
less carbon intensive food ecosystem
means adding coaching capacity and
adding it quickly
and since i'm talking to about 200 of
you who will be future business leaders
i want to talk about what you can do
as your companies rethink about your
supply chain in the post-pandemic world
it is imperative that you go beyond
the cookie cutter diversification or
near shoring strategies that your
consultants keep pitching you about and
think about the whole ecosystem
resiliency comes from strengthening the
entire supply chain and it begins with
investing in the most fragile lengths
like bringing roads bringing electricity
and bringing refrigeration to those
villages in burkina faso
tudor understood
that
until every port had an ice house there
was no cross-atlantic ice trade
similarly there is no resilient global
supply chain if farmers don't have the
infrastructure to store what they've
produced
this is also good for business
better cold storage at the point of
harvest meant fresher higher quality
produce for your company
it decreases food loss and also makes
for more predictable supplies this will
save you money and is also more
sustainable
and finally there's massive social
benefits
for the local community they'll
obviously get access to better safer and
more nutritious food but more
importantly the same set of cold storage
infrastructure will also provide access
to life-saving drugs and vaccines like
what we've seen in the last two years
the pandemic gave us an opportunity
to rethink and re-imagine what the
future called change should look like
let's take a page
from the ice kings playbook and start
investing in the weakest link in this
global system
only then will we be able to provide
freshness to all
resiliently sustainably and equitably
[Applause]
[Music]